le sénat a tout simplement supprimé de
la proposition de loi concernant le
pacte civil de solidarité le pacs un
amendement du rpr patrice gélard a été
voté par 216 voix contre 99 les sénateur
rpr udf et démocratie libérale ont
rejeté un texte où le pack serait pour
eux je cite un sou mariage qui ne veut
pas dire son nom
reportage à vis timbert et l'insead
martin vous dépassez les bornes
je suis une femme libre messieurs le
président de la commission des lois
même la traditionnelle ambiance feutrée
du sénat en a pris un coup
le pacs décidément ne saurait être
discuté sans passion ici
la droite s'est choisi un nouveau
porte-voix patrice gélard femme est
content d'obtenir la venue cet élu rpr a
fait voter rien moins que la suppression
du pacs à la place une nouvelle
définition du concubinage
la preuve selon lui que le sénat c'est
s'adapter quand on dit que quelqu'un est
ringard c'est quelqu'un qui n'arrive pas
à s'adapter
la celle inverse c'est nous qui nous
adaptons et c'est l'assemblée nationale
qui a proposé quelque chose d'irréaliste
et 10 réalisable
le résultat c'est qu'elisabeth guigou se
lance dans une nouvelle bataille
après le marathon de l'assemblée
l'automne dernier retour à l'explication
de texte
le pacs ce sont de nouveaux droits en
matière de succession en matière fiscale
un plus pour les couples non mariés
notamment homosexuels c'est ça qui me
redonne si vous voulez malgré la
répétition comme vous des arguments que
tout de même grâce à l'existence de ce
débat aujourd'hui très peu nombreux sont
les personnes qui osent ostracisé en
tout cas dans les hémicycles est les
homosexuels et c'est bien la question
centrale qui a aujourd'hui fait débat au
sénat
un couple peut-il être reconnue dès lors
qu'il unit deux personnes quel que soit
leur sexe il y a des concubins
hétérosexuels et c'est la majorité et il
y à un concubinage homosexuel et il est
temps de le reconnaître expressis verbis
ça ne sert à rien ces précautions
dans les tribunes réservées au public la
députée christine boutin elle a pu
assister ce soir au rejet du pacs par le
sénat projet de pure forme dans dix
jours
l'assemblée nationale rétablir le texte